get ready for a republican Royal Rumble
as another 20-24 Contender gets into the
race Florida Governor Ron DeSantis
officially filing paperwork to run for
president he will sit down with Trey
Gowdy on Fox News tonight for his first
television interview at 8 pm Eastern the
fantas's wife getting things started by
putting out this teaser video
is it worth the fight
do I have the courage is it worth the
sacrifice
America has been worth it every single
time
former Trump wasting former president
Trump wasting no time going after
DeSantis saying that the Florida
governor can't win and needs a
personality transplants brand new poll
shows Trump gaining support and doubling
his lead over to Santa since March but
DeSantis appears ready for a fight his
allies are expected to spend up to 200
million dollars to try and defeat Trump
and the liberal knives are out for the
Florida governor Hillary Clinton
tweeting quote Ron desantis's Ultra Mega
Florida isn't safe for people of color
lgbtq plus people or even multi-billion
dollar corporations and the media is
getting in on bashing DeSantis
I don't want to dislike you I can't help
it why do you dislike people of color
what's wrong with American history yeah
what's wrong with gay folks you're
seeing uh his lack of political skills
and his lack of political judgment and
maybe a little bit of a whiff of
desperation here it's obvious that Ron
DeSantis is a white supremacist right
this is not a freedom agenda this is a
do what Ron DeSantis tells you to do the
state owns you agenda
well Gene it seems like they're pretty
upset about it but will does Santa see a
huge boost in polling after today uh or
did he wait too long to announce so I
don't have a crystal ball so I don't
know what the polls will show but I I
personally am glad that this is now that
we're going to actually see the peeling
back of the curtain because we've been
talking about DeSantis might run for so
many months now that this is going to be
good to like finally get it started
president Trump's team has spent about
15 million dollars and had really helped
to drive down to Santa's poll numbers
one of the narratives was they're trying
to kill this baby in the Cradle like
they do not want this baby to be able to
announce a run for president he was as I
can understand it and I don't know his
team I don't talk to them I don't so
this is my observations they wanted to
wait until after the legislative session
so that he could say here you want a
Conservative Republican nominee here's
what I can do for you look at all of my
accomplishments and he can list them off
and he's super articulate and deepen the
Weeds on policy so he will be able to do
that he also has this healthy disdain
for the media which I think Republican
primary voters appreciate president
Trump was able to
um
he didn't have a disdain for them he
could work with them and he drove the
media crazy the media is also being
driven Crazy by Rhonda Santos because he
ignores them and they don't like that so
it'll be interesting to see how that
goes so I don't know how the polling
will go I do think it's interesting to
see that other Republican candidates who
have already announced that they're
either thinking of running or they've
already gotten in they don't attack
president Trump but they're they feel
free and clear to attack Ron DeSantis
who do they think the real threat is
that's something I'm interested to watch
tonight yeah that'll be very interesting
yeah and you know Brian
um in a uh uh Trump DeSantis poll
Quinnipiac Trump 56 DeSantis 25 since
March Trump has gone up nine points
DeSantis has gone down eight points does
any of that mean anything now that
DeSantis is in the race if he's got game
and I think he does we've already seen
60 minutes try to take him on and others
and he really thrives when he's
challenge so I don't think that'll be an
issue but if
he's going to be if he steps up and he
just performs like he did two weeks ago
in Iowa he had two appearances I watched
them both we carried one on the Saturday
show and I watched one in the afternoon
and then on his Instinct he goes to the
exact place that Donald Trump had to
cancel in Des Moines because the weather
and he Trump did the right thing
canceling but he goes let me go to the
let me go to the uh the restaurant right
around there and he went there and he
shook hands and he seemed to be thriving
so Donald Trump was able to run up the
score because Donald because Ron
DeSantis wasn't in the game I just want
to see if when Ron DeSantis hears you're
Banning books what's his answer when he
hears you don't like American history
you don't want to bring up slavery
what's his answer and what can you
expand on anti-wolk he's not looking at
banned books we know what he's doing
right we know he's not he's not against
American history he's against the
skewing of American history but he
hasn't answered now answer and I I
really think he should take On All or
sit down with all media not just people
that like him because he does not he
it's one of his strengths you know
Herald one of the things that Brian's
talking about about is so important and
that is you know how is it going to
answer those questions I mean he's not I
mean the left has been has had so much
time to attack him and you think Ron
desensis oh he's Banning books well no
he's Banning him for seven-year-olds but
he has to explain the drop in his
popularity that you decided judge how
did he lose all of that support over the
last couple of months is it possible as
I think so uh that this whole war on
woke war on Walt Disney war on uh you
know A diversity inclusion Equity all
the rest of that stuff is not enough now
uh you mentioned at the top of the show
Casey DeSantis his wife she's Brave
she's Charming she could be his secret
weapon I think that if they come out and
she's supporting him the way Jackie
Kennedy that's the image they are trying
to evolve and they all look and they
they seem to costume uh to to be
reminiscent of that era uh if she can
you know cap that magic and and the
Santas can get out of this uh you know
this armadillo armor uh going after all
the Mickey Mouse uh you know he could be
a very very interesting candidate and
he's going to use age like you wouldn't
believe I mean I I'm friends with
Charlie Crystal at his wedding uh when
he had the final debate with Charlie
Chris the old governor of Florida uh you
know running against the Sanders he got
his tail kicked and uh desanta said of
uh Charlie Chris because everyone was
saying you can run against Trump you can
run this truck he said uh Charlie Chris
the only worn out donkey I'm looking to
put out to Pastor is Charlie Chris and
worn out donkey I think that that's
going to be his approach he's going to
be scornful of people with age on them
okay all right Jimmy wrap it up wrap it
up uh on some level there's a part of me
that admires anybody who runs for
president just because I'd never passed
a background check so uh the fact that
they've gotten that far well you're way
ahead of me
Geraldo shots fired uh let me jump in
here really quick you can tell by the
media reaction that DeSantis is the guy
they feel threatened by because they're
already coming at him with everything
imaginable you know the old adage when
you have the facts pound the facts when
you have nothing pound the table they're
pounding the table pretty aggressively
he didn't ban books he clearly didn't
ban gay people anybody who thinks
Florida band gay people has never been
to Key West okay they're having a
fabulous time down there as they should
but where DeSantis has more traction
Than People realize is he's leading the
way in a lot of policies that people
agree with but don't feel comfortable
speaking too out loud and a good example
of that would be the parental rights and
education Bill parents supported that
bill Democrats called it don't say gay
and parents kind of stood back but if
you're a parent as I am you realize
we're living in an America where one in
three kids can't read at a grade level
okay if you're a guy who wants to focus
on education as opposed to the people
who want to give your kid a drag show
from some guy named Cinnabons I'm
telling you you're scoring with parents
and he's got a lot of upward Mobility
you know what's interesting is that
DeSantis is the only one with a military
background among all of them and I
wonder how that plays rather I think the
main reason why his numbers went down is
he's been attacked relentlessly by an
expert yes an expert who's putting
together good ads with the best team
he's ever had this is his best team and
for the most part Ronda Santos only
subtly answered back now you'll see if
he's got anything because he put the
gloves on but the judge recalls his uh
military service when was the last time
you saw a picture of him in uniform yeah
the wedding yeah I mean I I think you
should more emphasize this I can't wear
it now I mean you know
don't miss this Governor Ron DeSantis
will join Trey Gowdy on Fox News tonight
at 8 pm Eastern I winner Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming anyway
on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now